back all right so our next presentation
is
in Berkeley but uh probably in the hotel
in Berkeley
I don't I see you on the screen there
Joel but you are feeling ill or
something so that's why you do this
online yeah anyway uh I don't know if
you see us do you see us or not or yes I
do a little bit okay
um so if people have questions during
the talk you can try to
sort of just quit asking if Joel doesn't
hear it I can in the microphone maybe uh
repeat the question but anyway you will
talk about the
uh contagions and hybrid phase
transitions the floor is yours all right
thank you thank you
um great to be here
um so yeah so I'm going to be talking
about some work that I've done in the
past so this isn't uh incredibly recent
work but this is a work that I've been
doing uh and hope to get back to a
certain amount to discussing complex
contagions if you can tune up your
volume that would be nice
okay let me see what I can do uh what
microphone is it using
it's using this microphone
um
it's good now maybe someone in the
control room yes okay that could be all
right so yeah so I'm going to be talking
about some work that uh I did a little
while ago and I've been hoping to get
back to kind of the
regime of thinking about information
spread uh the reason being that uh I
think that information spread is a
really important thing in particular
misinformation spread and rumors and
such
um I think that both politically and as
we've now discovered for Health Care uh
this is a really important uh issue to
to be thinking about
so let's
let's talk a little bit about what I'm
going to talk about
um I'm going to talk about Sir disease
and I'm also going to talk about a
similar model uh basically a
generalization in some sense of Sir
models uh the watch threshold model this
was by Duncan Watts
um who I believe was a PhD student of
Steve's drug I took one stage certainly
they work together
um and
I'm also going to discuss a model of
random networks uh you guys are familiar
with configuration model networks and
some of you may be familiar with the
fact that there are clustered networks
that are of similar structure to
configuration model that works uh in
that they have something like a
tree-like behavior so we can do some
some of the same analysis uh with a bit
more effort but we can do some of the
same analysis that we can do for
configuration model Networks I'm going
to put all of this stuff you see there
the watch social goggle and these
clustered random networks into a
mathematical framework that lets me uh
predict something about the Dynamics of
the watch threshold model
and some interesting behaviors will
emerge so I'll talk about phase
Transitions and probably a few other
things related to them
so let me start with uh just a review of
a concept from dynamical systems uh
which are cobweb diagrams
um
so in discrete dynamical systems we
often have this case where we have some
some point x which depends on time and
it's
um given by some function of uh then the
next point is given by a function of the
previous point so we've got a discrete
point we go from X of zero uh we find X1
we go to X1 we find X2 we go to x 2 and
we'll find X3 and we keep repeating that
and there's a fixed point of these Maps
now cobweb diagrams uh I'm assuming some
of you have seen this but perhaps not
all of you particularly the those of you
who think more about statistics uh are a
way of doing this iteration in kind of a
quick way you start off at x0 you go to
X1 and then instead of jumping over to
X1 here and looking up you just draw a
horizontal line to this point which is
at X1
uh so this is a point on the line Y
equals X and then you just go up and
then you go over to that line again you
go down you go over to the line and you
keep going around and you get something
that uh under certain circumstances
looks kind of like a spider web uh hence
the cobweb name
um
there's some nice stability issues and
of this uh namely if you're very near
the fixed point which we'll call
extility
uh so your X of T is 2 X is the fixed
point plus a small value then we could
do uh just a little bit of a Taylor
series think we say x till d uh plus
Epsilon of t plus one so that's your
next that's X of t plus one is your
function of X of T and I could do a
Taylor's expansion uh my leading order
term gets me f of x tilde but I've
chosen that to be my fixed point right
here so I get activity uh plus the
derivative the local derivative times
Epsilon at the previous time and so that
means that Epsilon of t plus one is this
map where we got Epsilon t plus one is
approximately a constant times Epsilon
of T if that constant is less than one
you're getting closer if it's bigger
than one you're getting farther away
from the fixed point so you learn about
stability and depending on the sign of
it
um you can also have it uh if if that
constant is negative so like in this
case the it's got a negative slope as
you go across here so F the derivative
is negative at that fixed point
um your you start once you get close
enough you start oscillating from one
side to the next each time you do the
iteration
uh if the derivative is positive but
lesson one you approach it but you
approach it uh kind of in a well in a
monotonic way
if the derivative is equal to zero uh
which I will talk a little bit about a
case like that the approach could be
very very very slow
foreign
now
um let's talk about Contagion
uh you guys are
uh pretty familiar with this sort of
thing
um I can go around and I change the
status of someone else in fact right now
perhaps if I were there I would be
changing the status of some of you guys
um through the fact that I I maybe have
a virus of some form
uh and this this version uh sometimes
referred to as a simple contagion a
single individual can cause you to
change your status
um in a rumored case it might be that
just hearing the rumor from one person
is enough to make you believe the rumor
um
but there's another version uh which is
that you know what I don't believe the
rumor you know just you know
particularly you know maybe it comes
from Greg and I'm not convinced that you
know raise a particular trustworthy
thing not the time to mention my
brother's name is Greg um but yeah uh
but you know I might I might hear
something from someone and well maybe
maybe uh you know it's plausible but I'm
not convinced
um but you know I go to my social media
and everybody's saying exactly the same
thing
um well then maybe I'm actually going to
believe it
um
yeah so you you go here uh the
particular example I've chosen there
um I don't know if you can read it but
uh an example from my life was you know
I heard from I heard one guy give a talk
where he explained how some interactions
of hailstones can cause charge to uh
this balance and charge from high and
the clouds to the ground level and that
that can cause lightning and I was
telling some uh people that and they
weren't really believing me so they
asked the guy who happened to be walking
past who's director of the center for
not only your studies if he knew what
caused lightning and he said exactly the
same thing so they believed us and then
I asked him you know who told you that
and his Source was exactly the same so
they took it as kind of independent
information and therefore they believed
it uh you know you hear from independent
sources is credible but you know
sometimes it's not really independent
sources and that I think is a really big
potential issue
um in our society right now you start to
you hear the information a few times you
think it's everybody's credible but
they're all getting it from the same
place
um so you're you're kind of judgment is
perhaps cute
okay so I I guess with this I want to
just get across this idea that there's a
complex contagion where you could hear
something from multiple places and
there'll be simple contagions where it
just takes a single uh into where the
the change in status is due to a single
interaction whereas here the change of
status is potentially due to multiple
interactions
that's funny
okay
I want to set the stage a little bit
more most of you guys are reasonably
familiar with this idea we've got
um a network we've got susceptible
individuals they can become infected
because of interactions with infected
papers and for me when I'm going to use
beta here I'm thinking about this as a
rate per Edge so per partnership so
there's a partnership at rate beta it
causes this transitions to happen and
then all of these other ones have a
potential rate of beta of causing
transitions to happen and one of them
happens and potentially at some later
stage somebody recovers so the recover
recovery happens this person recovers
with immunity uh the markovian bottle uh
that I'm going to use the fact that I
say these things happen with Riggs beta
gamma means that there's no reason to
expect that this initial infection would
recover any sooner than one of the other
infections
um so
you can certainly convince yourself of
this fact but it is uh it's worth
highlighting uh you know just being
aware of the back of your mind that our
models make that assumption and that may
not be an accurate uh assumption all the
time
in fact it's probably not an accurate
assumption and it may lead to kind of
some mistakes in how how we can how we
think about uh the outcomes of our
models
all right
um
and
I want to kind of represent these
transitions that can happen through a
pair of directed graphs there's two
types of transitions that happen there's
the S to I transition which happens
because of somebody else and there's the
eye to R transition which happens purely
because of things that are happening
within myself
um so I'm gonna think I've got an is
parent that can become an II pair a rig
beta and then I individual can become an
R individual array gamma so we've got
two kinds of transitions the transitions
that can be caused by one neighbor
the transitions that are caused by
internal Dynamics and I can think about
now I can represent a system where there
might be many many kinds of trans
transitions that can happen
um and I can encode all the ones that
could be caused by one neighbor
in uh in actually a directed graph uh
all the ones that can be caused by
somebody's own status so I could have
another node e goes to I I goes to R I
can have a direct graph that encodes all
these sort of internal Dynamics
um and it turns out that if we have that
framework
um we can
um
we can kind of build up a more General
classic models
um and for what it's worth it if you are
interested in doing these more
complicated sorts of transitions that
could earn systems where there are more
different states and people can trans uh
change status because of the Neighbors
in different ways
um I have software that can do that for
a network
okay
all right so still I'm giving a little
bit of introductory material here
I want to talk about the watch threshold
model so I'm going to slow down here
because this is likely to be new for a
lot of people
so it's like the sir model or more
specifically it's like the SI model
to think about it as s i
and I've got a susceptible individual
who has a bunch of Neighbors
that susceptible individual has uh
associated with him a threshold uh which
I'll refer to as R sub U so node U has a
threshold R sub U it's you could it
might as well be an integer positive
integer or non-negative integer
and once this individual has at least
that many infected Neighbors
it will transition to infected so for
example this node here has three has a
threshold of three and once uh he or she
is reached
um the uh value of three infected
Neighbors
there's a transition to infected
um it's not immediately obvious uh that
this is
um
that there's time in this there's or
more to the point there's multiple ways
that I can put time into it
um but if you have kind of these rules
that if I have at least three infected
neighbors I will eventually become
infected if we think about this
threshold in that way are they no matter
how you put time into it you'll get the
same final state
and you can create a dynamic model in
several different ways one of them is to
just say that once I reach my thresholds
I have a rate at which I will transition
to the state
there's multiple ways to put this in and
create something dynamic
um often we're just focused on when
we've studied these models on the final
State and I'm going to focus on that
um another way to put time in which will
be similar to what I what basically will
correspond to things you'll see later is
basically at one time step everybody
who's at their threshold transitions to
uh infected and then once you've done
that with everybody you go through it
now you look again uh you cycle through
again everybody who's now at their
threshold and transition them to
infected and you just keep repeating
that each time
at the start of the step you figure out
who is going to who has research
threshold and then those people will
transition at the end of that step
um I want to make
one comment uh for well
for an sir model uh it can be kind of
interesting
um exactly you know how you with if
you're careful about how you assign
these thresholds you can create the same
out final State as an sir model it's not
as simple as saying the threshold is one
you've got to assign a random random set
of values on these thresholds but you
can
um
if you choose them from the right
distribution you can create the final
size the final outcome of an sir
epidemic so this is in some sense a
generalization of the sir model and
there are actually a lot of models out
there uh that people use that can be uh
considered as special cases of this
so let me stop here I'll pause here and
just see uh I want to really make sure
you guys understand this model uh before
I move on
are there any questions here uh well I
can ask one question so you haven't
talked so much about the network so
there is an underlying Network that is
given to you or yes so I I think about
this as there is an underlying Network
so I think of a picture like this one uh
perhaps this individual has a threshold
of one
and this individual has a threshold of
one then what would happen is you get at
the first step this person becomes
infected stays infected uh at the next
step this one becomes infected stays
infected and if these people have a
threshold that's
two or more sorry is bigger than two if
they have a threshold that is equal to
two then at the next step they would
become infected uh this one clearly has
a threshold of bigger than one otherwise
it would have become infected
and I do not have a recovery but you
would have this sort of a picture and if
these people have a
threshold that's bigger than two we're
done nothing more is going to happen if
these two if one of them or either or
both has a threshold equal to two they
would become infected at the next step
thank you are there other questions
about the model
no it doesn't seem like it will continue
okay
all right cool
so so maybe one more question
so are these thresholds random or
individual based or uh there's various
rules on how we can assign them what I
what I'm thinking of here is that I
assign these thresholds randomly to the
each individual
um and from some distribution you could
also do it where that is coming from a
distribution that cares about my degree
so you could do it where if you know I
have a hundred contacts I might have be
expected to have a different threshold
than somebody who has five contacts
um you know so often it's done when you
reach some proportion of your
neighborhood is infected but here here
what I'm thinking about is just there is
some distribution that's out there and
we are going to use that distribution uh
we're going to choose for every single
person we'll choose a threshold from
whatever that distribution is
foreign
all right
one way I can do this with time I want
to talk a little bit about one way I
could do this with time
um
I I can basically think about this as
sort of a discrete uh time version where
what happens is if you're at your
threshold if you are an individual
you're susceptible you have a threshold
of one
you get immediately mapped to an
infected individual this eye and you've
got a new neighbor I that uh converts
you to an infected individual so if this
is you've got an infected neighborhood
you haven't interacted with before or
hasn't previously been infected you have
a threshold of one you become infected
or you start off with a threshold that's
bigger than one and as soon as you have
an infected neighbor you become somebody
who has a threshold of one less and we
no longer let that neighbor affect you
and so we we basically can build up a
directed
you know we build up a network that
consists of a whole bunch of edges that
look like this I to s r goes to i s r
minus one and we can kind of encode this
um I am interested that the edges only
transmit once
or another thing we could do
um is we could
we could actually make this P below one
and this would be sort of like this
would allow me to think about it as
um an sir state it would be possible to
have
um
something like this that that's another
option I could do I could I could
include a recovered state where somebody
stops influencing their papers and have
something where that transition isn't
guaranteed to happen
I I'm going to stick to the SI
formulation so I'm not going to have
this transition happening
all right
um for those of you who think about
networks
um there's a whole bunch of models that
can be shown to be equivalent to it or
special cases of it
um and k-core percolation there's
something people call heterogeneous
k-core there's something people are
actually there's more than one thing
that people call bootstrap percolation
uh that that caused me a lot of trouble
when I was studying this question
um there's some something in the
literature called the generalized
epidemic process you can make site
percolation become a special case of
this and you can make bottom preparation
um if you think about what the final
component looks like of uh the the final
giant components basically say
preparation Bond propulation
okay or actually the entire component
distribution can come from this
all right
now this next one I think a lot of you
are aware of but I I think it's a nice
demonstration
um you know you guys know configuration
model networks
um you're probably aware of the fact
that your friends have more friends than
you do you may even be aware that uh
configuration model networks can help
explain why that's true
um and so what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to take a population where
there is there are three everybody has
either degree three or degree one and I
start off as I'm going to trade it by
giving each person either three or one
stud
and I'm going to choose a random pair of
stubs I'm going to construct it and
we're going to build up a configuration
model Network
that's the model
um but
unfortunately the numbers we have uh in
that room don't look very large but
there's what I'd like you guys to do is
each of you choose one of these notes uh
try to do it at random so you don't
choose the same as somebody else uh and
we're gonna look at a few images and I'm
going to ask you questions about your
node and you can raise your hand
so look at your node choose it I'm going
to give them some stubs
if your note has degree three could you
raise your hand
okay if your node has degree one
all right that looks kind of like about
half and half
um ugly people seem to be really bad
random number generators and very often
that doesn't happen
um but it's about half and half and
that's what should happen uh half of
these notes have degree three half of
them have degree one now in the next
image I'm going to wire this network up
and I want you to you're going to choose
one of the edges coming from your node
and look at the neighbor along that edge
and
so the same node choose one of the
Neighbors at random
now if your neighbor has degrees three
can you raise your hand
okay and if the neighbor has degree one
okay we should have gotten about three
times as many to have degree three as
one and the reason for that is because
the probability of your neighborhood's
degree K is proportional Decay this is
for an infectious disease this is
incredibly important because those High
degree people uh they get infected
sooner and they and that they transmit
to more people uh this is particularly
for sexual networks this is a big deal I
think it's what's driving the really the
initial growth of monkey pox but it's
also driving the fact that monkeypox uh
has is kind of crashing really you know
without having nearly as many cases as
you would expect for uh a disease that's
grow that initially grew as fast as it
did as because these high degree
individuals are getting infected and
then uh it's it's only now at once they
they've been infected they've recovered
there's really only low degree
individuals left uh it can still infect
them but it's just can't sustain itself
nearly as well
all right
yeah so the key property
um
yeah there's a key property that makes
kind of the sort of approach
mathematical approach I use work which
is that if you've got a node U and we've
got two Neighbors being w
ow
um their statuses are going to be
independent of one another if I'm the
only in a configuration model network if
I'm the only uh
you know I'm I have both of them as
neighbors but until I've had some
influence on their statuses there's no
reason to expect them uh to be uh
dependent on each other there's no
reason that I can treat them as
independent until I've affected their
status
um and then once I've affected their
status that tells you that I must be in
the infected state or sir I could be
recovered
and then there's nothing that they can
do
um to affect me so until
they have uh until I transmitted to one
of them
I meant their statuses are independent
once I'm infected I don't care about
their statuses anymore
um
and only internal things can happen to
me so
what what that mean what that means is
that basically when we build up a model
we can kind of assume that all my
neighbors are independent until I'm
infected and then once I'm infected I
don't care about the fact that they they
get uh dependent on each other and this
is uh this is really important in
configuration models it helps us to
write down some nice systems of
equations and it helps explain why this
edge-based compartmental models that
I've created works but it also helps
explain why people when they use pair
approximations uh those approximations
are actually correct in these large
population limit rather than being in
approximation in the large population
limit
I would like to create clustered
networks where this kind of property is
close to right
so I want to introduce clustering I want
to maintain Independence
um this was published by Mark Newman in
2009 and by me in 2009 in fact a week
apart we published basically the same
paper
um
what I'm going to do
is
I'm going to say I'm going to create a
cluster Network now when I say cluster
networks that means they're short Cycles
specifically here I'm going to have
triangles in my network I'm going to
create triangles in such a way that I've
got two neighbors who can interact with
each other
but if my neighbors V and W here
uh interact with each other they're
going to interact with no other
neighbors of mine
and that is going to build something
that's kind of tree-like
um
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
do something kind of like the
configuration model I'm going to give
people two different types of uh Edge
dubs
and I'm going to join one set into
groups of three of the other set into
pairs
we can also think about this as being
kind of like a hyper graph so a
configuration model equivalent of a
hypograph that has edges and edges with
three nodes would give you this
but we we end up with a Network that has
triangles because we've got things
joined into groups of three and regular
edges
something like this
and
in many ways it's still very much like a
um
a tree-like network you know we've got
branches this Branch doesn't interact
with this Branch this Branch doesn't
interact with this Branch you know it's
the only way that I can have two nodes
be correlated is if they are part of a
triangle and I I will have to do more
work to analyze the spreading process on
these Networks
but I can I can make good progress I I
can still uh you know I have to worry
about how these two notes are correlated
when I think about what's going on with
the central guy but I don't need to
worry I can treat everybody else as
independent of the correlations between
these two nodes
I'm going to create a joint distribution
of degrees I've got an individual can
have M pairs in in triangles
the this so the the key thing here is
that we're generalizing configuration
model networks in a way that allows us
to introduce some clustering
um but still be able to do some of the
calculations that uh we we know and love
the configuration model for
all right so I'm going to now build up
the mathematical models
um and I'm going to make uh two kind of
axiomatic like planes
oh that let me sort of build a large
population limit here
the fraction of the population with a
given State should be equal to the
probability a random node has that state
so if I'm in the case where I could do
this love large number of sorts of
things I could I could calculate the
probability uh of something and that
gives me the proportion of the
population that are in that state
um so in a sense this is very closely
related uh to what Greg was talking
about
um in the previous lecture
and
if I alter a node so that you know I
choose one node out there and I do
something to it so that it cannot
transmit after infection
this has no impact on its own state
okay so I'm in the sir epidemic uh and
I'm going to choose one person in an sir
epidemic and I'm going to say that
person randomly chosen from the
population is somehow uh unable to
transmit to others because of an act of
God
can still get infected still recovers
under the same rules but just for some
strange reason cannot infect others
then there is nothing about that random
individual's
um status that is different from any
other random individual status in the
original population where he was able to
transmit
and
I'm going to call this individual a test
note
and the status the if I can calculate
the probability that this test note has
a given status given that the test mode
is randomly chosen from the population
that will give me the proportion of the
population that has H status and my
original population where I didn't have
a special especially behaving test node
and so calculating the probability of my
test node has a given status will give
me the probabilities the proportion of
the population in my original world that
has that given says but because I
prevented this individual from
transmitting I have independence of his
neighbors I don't have to worry about
his status the status of his status is
independent of the status of his
neighbors or doesn't affect the status
of its neighbors
so I can I can basically ignore him when
I'm uh thinking about the status of his
neighbors
all right I'm gonna do stuff in discrete
time
and
if I've got somebody who has degree k
um
and let me look at this for a moment
yeah
I'm I'm now thinking about the what's
threshold model where somebody can
receive some number of Transmissions
over time so I've got somebody with
degree k
the probability that he has that this
randomly chose individual has received
at least M Transmissions
given degree k
is basically k2's and where Theta is the
probability that a random neighbor has
not yet transmitted to me so in my sir
model those of you who've seen what I
did uh I didn't need M to be bigger than
one so I didn't get into all this but
now I'm in a case where I may require
multiple Transmissions before I
um change status so I need to know
what's probability I've received at uh
exactly in Transmissions well it's a
probability that I have I looked at all
my neighbors who haven't transmitted to
me
um their status in the K minus m
one minus Theta to the m
if I've yeah I'm not doing that sorry
let me
look at this for a moment
yeah
um yeah so I've got K I choose M of M
I'm going to look at uh failures that
came out soon
I may
something's looking a little bit odd to
me but
yeah okay the probability that I'm
susceptible
um is then the problem is the sum over
all these things those lesson are
k2's M
um Theta to the K minus M when my Theta
to the m
so if my thresholders are the
probability I'm so susceptible is the
probability I've received some number of
Transmissions less than my threshold
um and now I'm going to just sort of sum
these up over all the different possible
States I've got I'm going to sum up
um
the probability that I have a degree K
the probability I have a threshold of R
the probability that I've received fewer
than our
transmissions and then I'm going to sum
that up over all of my different degrees
and then this will get me the
probability of random node is
susceptible
uh time t
there is a way to kind of Express this
big sum uh compactly in terms of the
Taylor series or a truncated Taylor
series uh I don't want to go there
there's not much benefit uh to doing
that
um but uh if you've read my paper or if
you're looking at this and saying why
doesn't he do that kind of
simplification I I'd like to just leave
everything kind of explicitly expanded
out here
okay so this is what this is again just
to go through I choose a random
individual the probability he's
susceptible depends on his degree
that have threshold uh and then I look
at the probability that he has a
particular threshold and that degree
and then I look at the probability that
he has received fewer than his threshold
numbers of Transmissions
and I add up everything
so
okay I've I'm looking for sft
I've now pushed this problem up into
figuring out Theta of T So if I know
Theta of T great
um but I I haven't told you that but if
I know Theta of T I know s of T Theta of
T again is the probability that a random
neighbor of mine has not yet transmitted
to me
so I have to figure that out so to
figure out the probability of random
personally said well we need to answer
in terms of the probability of random
labor hasn't transmitted so if I if I
know if I know that I can answer the
question I actually care about
okay well so I'm going to look at my
random neighbor and what's the
probability how do I think about my
neighbor not transmitting to me my
neighbor hasn't transmitted me yet maybe
because he's still susceptible I'll call
that Phi s or maybe he's infected but he
hasn't yet transmitted to me
um and in the model that I've got which
is this discrete time that at each time
step that person is going to transmit to
me uh if he is infected
then Theta is bias plus by I but my next
Theta is my current Theta minus Phi I so
if my neighbor is currently infected but
hasn't yet transmitted to me then at the
next time step my neighbor has
transmitted to me so that that term that
goes away and I've got fire so I can
figure out Theta of t plus one in terms
of Phi s okay so I want to know the
probability I'm susceptible I know that
in terms of the probability my neighbor
hasn't transmitted to me by time T which
I now know in terms of the probability
my neighbor was still susceptible at
time T minus one
so we just need to work out I'll go to
my neighbor hasn't transmitted to me by
time T minus one
and
I've got
um I do exactly the same calculation
except that I don't worry for my
neighbor for Greg you know the
probability Greg has passed on a rumor
to me
um I'm not interested in whether I fed
that ruler to him and he passed it back
to me I'm ignoring that case that would
be more like an SIS kind of model and
those get horribly complicated and
difficult I'm only interested in Greg
where the great has translated to me
because he'd learned about the rumor
from someone else or some group of other
people
um so
s of T is the probability I'm
susceptible Phi s is a probability that
Greg is susceptible
um notice there's this minus one here
because I'm not worrying about me
transmitting to him
um and notice that there's a scaling
Factor I've got the probability Greg has
degree K well clearly Greg is somebody
who I trust enough to care about the
rubrics it gives me so he he has at
least one person who trusts him so Greg
has a degree at least one but in fact
you know he probably has more friends
than I do because he's my friend
um so
um so there's this Factor here the K
divided by by the single brackets I mean
the population average of K
so
what magically comes out of this is that
for greatest probability of being
susceptible at the current time I know
that in terms of theta
which
I've worked out how to figure out Theta
in terms of bias uh so we can I know
beta uh Phi s in terms of theta of T I
know Theta of T in terms of Phi s of T
minus one so I now know Phi s of T in
terms of
is of T minus 1 and therefore I've
worked out all my thetas
why is there no binomial coefficient in
the later Express
um probably because of a typo
um
yeah
um
so let's do that real quick
okay I I think that's just a typo
thank you
yeah yeah it's exactly the same
calculation it's just that uh he's
likely to have a higher degree K than me
so I've gotta I've got to weight his
probability of having degree K because
of K uh because his K is probably higher
and I don't care about me transmitting
to him so otherwise it's exactly the
same uh let me actually put that
correction that correction factor I'm
going to put that right here so this guy
here is the equivalent of P of K
uh for Greg accounting for him having
higher degree with higher probability
um because he's my friend uh and yeah I
need to choosing thank you
okay
all right so
what am I going to do well first for
kind of as I are like disease uh these
thresholds are GM that I can think I can
come up with an sir equivalent model if
I make this uh threshold distributed
geometrically I won't go into details of
explaining that but what ends up
happening is that if I've got Theta on
my horizontal axis state of t plus one
on my vertical axis so a horizontal axis
is stated of t
vertical axis is a state of t plus one
um then I've basically got a map that
I'm going to think of as a cobweb
diagram where
I've got some some function here and I'm
going to go from Theta of T to Theta t
plus 1 to Theta of t plus two Etc
and if I think about my initial
infections I'm going to assume are
randomly distributed initially
uh so I start off with some random
proportion of the population just uh out
there then it turns out that Theta of t
plus one is some function of theta of T
where that function happens to depend on
rho
um
and
I happen to have this property that F of
one is equal to one minus row so I start
off with beta of T I have a random
proportion of the population growth is
infected so it and my very first time
step with probability row I get a
transmission from one of my random
neighbors now some of my neighbors may
have just become infected so at the next
time step I you know I I jump over here
and I kind of step forward like a
cardboard diagram but I end up with this
fixed Point here
so this is what happens when you're kind
of subcritical uh you start off with an
epidemic you're subcritical you get a
little bit you know if you infect a
proportional row of the population in a
subcritical epidemic it will grow
uh a little bit you know it's not going
to go back to the original disease-free
uh equilibrium where everybody's
susceptible it's going to go to a new
equilibrium where some a few people are
infected and a few more than you started
with but it'll go to this fixed point or
you know if you have more people
infected it'll go to that fixed point or
if you start off with more people
infected it'll end up at this fixed
point
but it's doing something like this
that's if uh turns out to be if
um if the derivative here uh is less
than one
happens and that corresponds to or not
being less than one
are not greater than one this slope
becomes positive or sorry greater than
one uh same general kind of picture but
now what happens is we start off at
theta equals one we go to here we bounce
down to here we put go over we go over
we go over
um let me do I show that on the next
slide yeah so what happens here is that
our cobweb diagram looks like that and
you end up at this fixed Point way over
here
whereas in the case where our knowledge
lesson one the cobweb diagram looks
something like this and you end up with
the fixed Point that's very close to no
transmission
so you get two very different behaviors
out of the configuration model network
with an sir epidemic
and even in the row going to zero limit
and the row going to zero limit here
basically nothing happens and the road
going to zero limit here you still end
up at this fixed Point way down here
and you can see a little bit of the
final size changes a little bit if you
start off with a few more initial
infections
this is what happens for some cases with
the watch threshold model
we no longer have the situation where
right here what's going on is these
functions are all have positive second
derivative so they're all kind of
behaving like this
um the basically the derivative is
changing monotonically
once threshold model can do something
different
um you can have a picture where it comes
up like this it crosses the line Y
equals X and then it crosses back again
in the limit where row goes to zero
you're still hitting you still have to
go through this point
um but where you cross here you know
somewhere it could be somewhere up here
um
but basically what happens as your
initial proportion infected goes up
this kind of this moves down and you can
see that there's going to be a change of
behavior
if you're below a threshold you get
something that looks like this which is
a lot like
um the what you saw see for the sir
model subcritical
and what you see is that I as a function
of time goes up a little bit but
eventually is constant so you start off
you increase a little bit and then it's
basically constant
at threshold
you get this picture
um you start here you bounce over and
you bounce over and you start to
approach this uh equilibrium which is
tangent uh notice it this fixed point
it's tangent to this curve and so what
happens is you start to it takes a very
very long time to approach that and what
tends to happen is you start off with
some value of I it increases a little
bit quickly and then it remains flat for
a very long time
if you have a a finite population where
you're doing something stochastic
sometimes stochastic effects could make
it jump across you know if somebody has
a slightly uh lower you've chosen
everybody's threshold from a
distribution but it turns out you got a
few more people with the small threshold
and so it bounced across here or it was
the the way that the network was wired
the thresholds happened to be such that
you had a few more people with a small
threshold in one area and if you can
bounce basically get past this fixed
point you do see this happen where you
got something where it's coming up it
seems to stabilize and then
stochastically it suddenly jumps up
the convergence
basically what happens uh you get
Epsilon t plus one is when you're close
to this fixed Point Epsilon t plus one
is Epsilon of t
plus something that is really really
small
um because
let me just leave it at that
above the critical threshold what
happens is you get this picture you get
your uh opinion that's spreading and it
seems to be stabilizing nothing's
happening nothing's happening nothing's
happening and then oh
it starts to grow again and then
stabilizes again so you can get these
pictures where you've got something that
starts it grows for a little bit and
then it stops or it seems to stop it
doesn't quite stop and then it takes off
again
and these are you know yeah think about
this as an opinion
um once it you know it it's spreading uh
once it gets past some level suddenly
people start to believe it uh again you
know it might have initially been
spreading through a group of people who
are relatively ready to accept something
you've got a a group of conspiracy
theorists who are quite happy to believe
uh that uh all mathematicians all
mathematical modelers are lying
um but if there's enough of them out
there you know it starts to spread
through the conspiracy theorists gets
um it's getting through them and then
suddenly it starts to become mainstream
um and you can see this perhaps in the
Republican part well I I guess maybe I
shouldn't do that you can see this in uh
some of the uh world right now where uh
there are people who you know ideas that
used to be very Fringe ideas
um have become mainstream in some
communities
um so I guess yeah I would say you could
see that in the Republican Party
um I think it's probably fair that you
know other people might say something
about that
um in the uh Democratic party
um or in other groups you know you can
look at ideas that have been around for
a long time but are finally uh suddenly
starting to become uh widespread
foreign
s uh here uh if I just look at the final
size as a proportion of the initial set
of infections you know if I look at how
many people are are initially seated
with this
um in in where this picture emerges what
happens is if you start off with too
small of the proportion with this idea
the idea just doesn't spread uh doesn't
get anywhere
um as it if you start off with a larger
proportion it eventually gets bigger if
you start off really close to this
threshold what ends up happening is uh
this uh basically is like a final size
relation
it's looking sort of like a square root
fish Behavior it's becoming vertical at
this point
and then once you get past that
threshold there's this discontinuous
jump
uh and you're somewhere off like this
and then it stabilizes all right it's
getting close to Infinity close to
everybody
so you get this very weird sort of
transition here uh where as you tune
your control parameter which in this
case I've got to be the initial
proportion who are
um infected but you could imagine cases
where you're
you know control parameter is the
proportion of people who have a given
threshold
um you know there is some parameter of
the threshold the distribution of
thresholds you can get this very strange
kind of jump it's not a continuous thing
like what you have in an sir model where
you've got
you know you've got a
epidemic dies out and then suddenly once
you pass the threshold uh you get this
big growth but it's you know it's still
a small threshold here once you get past
that threshold there's a massive jump uh
and this is something that an opinion
bottles is kind of concerning to me
um you know I I don't know I don't know
what that's necessarily a good thing or
bad thing
um I have questions yes please
um so normally we saw yesterday some
thoracic markets and things like that
they actually says transition looks very
sharp but it looks different yes it
doesn't diverge and you could
theoretically go along a meta stable
phase a little while whereas here you
seem not to have that so from the top it
looks as a baby it looks like it could
go into a metal stable thing and
continue but for Autumn it seems to have
infinite derivative yeah yeah so that's
there are typical for firstborn of face
transition so what happens here
What's Happening Here I fundamentally
What's Happening Here is that there's
some weird some weird thing that's going
on uh as we go through this sort of
State it's not
um so
so the picture that is happening with
the sir model
is that
um basically as your are not as changing
this initial slope is changing
um and so when you start off with a very
small number of infections if our knot
is less than one that slope the slope at
uh the endpoints basically are not if R
naught is less than one this crosses and
it cross you know it crosses it doesn't
cross tangent or anything it just
crosses uh and then as R naught gets
close to one this is move you know the
point of this intersection starts to
move really quickly
um and so in the limit where rope row
your initial proportion effect is going
to zero
in a sense you don't care about the fact
that that
slope is getting close to one because
you're starting off so close to this
fixed point that it still crosses very
close but once you jump past the slope
of one you're no longer going to have an
intercept very close here uh The
Intercept is going to have to be way
down here
yeah sure yeah I
and when you cross here I understand
this picture too it's a standard first
officer okay yeah but what is strange is
that the boundary of your first order of
Faith transition usually you would get a
second order phase transition right the
thing is not a typical second order
first transition because in addition to
the Divergence you get to jump so it's
this and I don't understand it's a very
unusual you don't see physics yeah it is
very unusual it is it can be understood
at least mathematically through this
picture that you know as it crosses it's
Crossing tangent it's tangent to the
point where this cross happens so
basically you this
um over in the sir case basically what
what's happening is that that
intersection uh moves to kind of a you
know where the slope is greater than one
there's still an intersect intercept but
it's out here at this greater than one
case where I don't care about it
um and you're going to another fixed
point
here that fixed point is just Vanishing
there's something you know sort of
Saddle notice kind of about this where
the fixed point that you're trying to
converge to just disappears
no but I don't see it so if I take your
curves there and I move it slowly until
it becomes tangent right the point that
attention actually doesn't move
discontinuously that actually moves
continuously in diet jump in your
picture you claim that the slope yeah
okay okay so so yeah let's talk about
that that
um
it is
okay so basically as I increase row I
slide down and this point moves a little
bit this point is moving as Road changes
um if you think about this point as a
function of rho
because these things are getting closer
and closer to tangent a small change in
row really is actually resulting in a
larger and larger change in where this
intercept is
so as I basically slide if I took this
picture and I slid it down
um you know I started off here
up here I slide it down there's an
intercept right at one it's moving but
as I slide it down
uh this function the blue curve is
you know getting its tangent right at
this point
so it really is moving very quickly I I
can point you to where I've done the
analysis on it
um but you know fundamentally what is a
small change in row when this crosses
transversely when it just goes right
across it doesn't make a very big change
but as but if this thing were almost
tanned if this thing were
basically almost tangent that small
change in row that small move of this
function
you know you've got two lines that are
almost tangent and you shift one of them
a little bit the place where they
intersect moves a lot potentially so let
me formulate it differently physics
language
and you have the mean filter the heavier
which looks like set typically
fluctuations destroys that behavior
so I wonder whether that's an artifact
of a mean field analysis it's a real
system Behavior it's differently okay so
if I do the simulations in the network
um I do see that as that close to that I
sometimes
uh see one basically what happens is
when I'm close to that threshold I get
one of two outcomes uh I can get an
outcome where stochastically I basically
do get across this point uh and I do get
this sort of it grows
and then it jumps and then it grows
again but I can also get things that
sarcastically don't get to that point
and stay a little bit below this line
um so so I do see in a large population
I never get a lot you know if I if I fix
how far away I am from this threshold so
I'm not quite at the critical value but
very close to it and I do a large enough
population
um then I do still get the it behaves
kind of deterministically
uh if I fix my population size
and I changed my row what's going to
happen is that I'm going to get to once
I get to some regime that row is close
to my threshold some of them are going
to stay small and some of them are going
to get big and that's uh I can't predict
our priori which it's going to be
so basically the I get two different
behaviors can happen
but my final State here is sort of it's
um you know this is a monotonic
infections are increasing in this model
my final state is you know has either a
modest number of infections or almost
everyone is infected but I don't know
which one it's going to be given my
population size
shall we
should microphone perhaps
I think in fact this behavior is not
unusual
um that this
square root Behavior at that
is happening because you're driving the
system all the way to the spinodal line
where the the by stability of a system
disappears where you don't have two
competing equilibrium anymore and you
actually see this in
essentially any first order phase
transition if you drive it all the way
to the edge of the hysteretic regime
what we're seeing here is in the mean
field class as Christian pointed out and
so for instance you see this in the mean
field treatment of the icing model you
get exactly this kind of behavior where
you get infinite gradient and then a
jump
and as Christian also mentioned the
reason you don't see this in real
systems is because of fluctuations that
typically you get before you get to the
spinal line you get nucleation and the
system will jump to the other
equilibrium on its own but in principle
in an infinite size system you would see
this infinite gradient and you would see
this I think in any
first order phase transition
if you treat it with mean fields
I think perhaps you know here there's
not quite the same sort of fluctuations
uh that you have like with the icing
bottle
um you know once you go to Audi stay in
I if I had something where there was a
little bit more you know fluctuating
back and forth I think that would
probably you know I would end up
somewhere very close to this threshold
and if there's fluctuations I would
eventually get past it
um and I would take off again
um
but I don't know
and you have just for your information
you have five more minutes yeah I I am
basically wrapping up uh I'll say if
so the final outcome so
we can think about what this functional
shape is it depends on the
um
the distribution of the thresholds it
depends on the degree distribution
um typically if you get a whole bunch of
people who have a threshold of one you
get something you can get something kind
of like this where if you start with a
larger and larger proportion infected
you get uh just kind of your normal
final size sort of thing basically if
there's a lot of people who the
threshold this one
um it takes off very easily and
there was a hypothesis uh in Watts
initial model that the only way you
could start from sort of a zero case so
right at row equals zero nothing happens
but row at all positive you jump up here
um so Duncan Watts made a prediction
that uh our hypothesis I guess that the
only way you could have a jump like this
was if there was a lot of R equals one
individuals in the population
uh basically that they provide are a
giant component of the population
um but I can go to clustered networks
I'm not going to go through all the
details but I can get to similar sets of
equations
um and I can get a case where basically
I can get these sort of global Cascades
from row being uh arbitrarily small
um which can happen not if the
thresholds of one individual is sort of
form a giant component within the
population but if you've got a case
where you've got basically a triangle
where you've got a lot of triangles out
there where one individual has threshold
one
and somebody else has uh and I have
threshold two so if my name if one
neighbor has thresholds one I have
threshold two and my other neighbor in
this case I've written it with threshold
one but actually could have some other
threshold but note these forms that wave
it it gets into my triangle W then
magnifies them because W has threshold
one now my threshold of two means that I
get infected as well and if one of my
other triangles has an individual
threshold one and threshold of two then
it would immediately spread through that
other triangle as well so you can get
this kind of uh in a clustered Network
you can actually get uh Global Cascades
even if row is initially
arbitrarily small so your initial
proportion that actually believes your
um
the rumor is arbitrarily small if there
are small cycles that are small cliques
or something where some of the
individuals have a low threshold and
they basically magnify it within my
clique and it gets into my click from
somewhere else starts to spread my
clique and I believe it because well
there's a lot of my friends believe this
and it's just because my friends were
gullible or were had particular insights
or whatever it is that's driving the uh
opinion model to go
I think that that's basically it I want
to give an advertisement for uh people
who might have mathematical biology
questions I uh I'm trying to create a
repository so that we don't just teach
mathematics through biology or sorry
through physics examples I'd like to
start producing some disease and biology
and health applications there's a lot of
them for mathematics so I'm creating a
repository of that if anybody's
interested in using or contributing to
that
um talk to me
um my final kind of comments here look
uh for those of you who haven't seen
cobweb diagrams I know many of you have
they're fun
um they're uh there can be for these
complex contagions there could be some
really non-trivial interactions between
complex contagions and the network
structure
um and you can get these really dramatic
phase transitions uh to exist that
um are not the normal ones people talk
about and I think that's it yeah thank
you
thank you very much there were several
comments and questions during the
presentation as usual which is nice but
are there more comments or questions
can you show the previous slide
this one the advertisement or the okay I
was making notes on the yeah link
I I can share it as well
um uh I can turn the sides with you as
well you can email me uh and I can
definitely get you to that at the moment
it's basically just a GitHub repository
where I'm creating issues which uh
currently are mostly just reminders to
myself of the idea but I'll be expanding
it out whenever uh there's not enough
infectious disease that I have to spend
all my time thinking about that
foreign
this critical thing I didn't quite
understand so rho was the fraction of
initially yeah starting off with some
people initially infected
um so to speak so if I go to yep
go back to where you saw the tangent
thing that was the one yeah ah this yep
not that one
so basically you had another slide where
there was one curve and it was tangent
this one yes so um
what does this mean does it mean that if
you start up here
maybe let's say this is five percent or
whatever yep you can get trapped at ten
percent or at the 90 is that how I
should Yeah Yeah so basically uh if I if
I'm in a finite population that's hey
bro is five percent what happens is I
start off I'm I'm a person in the
population five percent of the
populations uh suddenly had this idea or
gotten infected somehow and so what
happens is that the next time step five
percent of
um that my neighbors have transmitted to
me uh so this is basically that data
variable
okay some of those people uh once five
percent
have transmitted to them you know
sometimes had a threshold of one some of
them had a threshold of two and it just
happened that two of their neighbors
were uh initially infected they became
infected and now they're going to a
small number of additional Transmissions
are going to happen yeah and it just
keeps going and yeah and does it mean
that if you would simulate this thing a
thousand times uh maybe if some of these
would yeah stop here and some would stop
you yeah if I mean uh if I'm in a finite
population some of them will basically
get stuck somewhere around here
um you know they they won't hit exactly
that point here because this is a
deterministic assumption that's gone
into it but some of them will get stuff
somewhere in here and some of them
because of a little bit of noise happen
to get past here and if they get past
that it takes off and it goes all the
way to here all right so it looks a lot
like this picture
it's a Pilots are fixed point right but
very Mighty but not so professor
I didn't quite hear that
yeah it's I want to be careful so it's
unstable from what yeah it's unstable
from one side it's neutral well it's
neutrally stable and if you go to the
second order the next order term it's
attracting from one side unstable from
the other side and noise can get you
past it
okay and if you're in a finite
population you you may not quite get to
it because it it just it's fine that you
can't get all the you know things stop
um
thank you Joel I think we reconvene at 2
pm is that correct or is it 1 30. so we
we convene at two okay before we close
this session let's thank Joel once again
thanks uh and I'm I'm going to take
another rapid test and if it comes up
negative I think if there's no
objections I'll come in
um this afternoon you know if you guys
don't want me yeah but if my next time
all of us have are bigger than or equal
to two all right all right yeah so I I
expect I'll be there for the afternoon
just yeah this morning I I want to be
sure
all right thanks guys